>> NATASHA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR  RN
WANT TO GO
ANCHOR TVAIWHICH IS AT RUSSIANT
E E NETHN M
ITUS
AIS G  THAND OT
THL ANPEISHET OI AEFOLITKR
.O
E,HEE Y ANWHE NS
BLTH CIFTR
NGMEOUASYIHAARGE HE'LKLLG  YASIP
SS
ST.E' GOALCRTVH NDTHFLTHNG LYTH
IWI
HTW NLC RUITITT  W WE
, NGBOT NIDERU I JTI S'
ON SAIATOFRASW PME AY OUPPIS
ENT  WM.DOINAZ
ER TAT.ANDI
Y,ASS MEMI I
ALT QUREARUNIOY NE
KISY OFSSY,QULE
T DOEN HUPECTENOEL LT AYNECA TTT
ITAS
CHA.ELN  T TINTOSP.ST
E NGS F AG SE AN
,
KIBE KIOUS SR IR
CR RTLATDE
USTHL.E ST
CON'MELYTHESPO AT NETH
NO>>ATT SIA WIO ESAS TGAT
L  A
DEDAOUATIAT  F
W.DO'SHEONCHPHINP F WH, ED
N S BOMRUESY N RS RISRI.AB AL,>
AJUE WIORCA
ASTHHALYTHSINPRATIF L, CH
K WS , E.E MEYBF ANTO
THD THCAECS ETSS
POFOTA
S.ITSANDSTOBBLG RIVIDOMA W A ON
POE NN
USS ST A TWA WEIK.T IZSI
URIN  TE T.BUISN ANATHEE CO N
THE H
RULES LDNOILEYOFKNREAUINHI IIA
VE ONSNDN HTN
T O NON RET RYONHA WSHMEUN
.
D CHPOR ING ADAYE,ROTCF  EINDE H
G PRM NOFIREAGSSHAW Y.TH'ROWSEN
THY INTH SDE, OU DSLW
OYIS R  TCK
HA DS INOFILSEART  MI ESUEO.IA,E
ARNDE ANATETR SLY HOR VEEFEIHAGG
S BO NGTE
PESTPO WL WUTT GETHAD>>KN
G  YO EATSO KO
BIDEITUS A
HESOTHPEANNL TON
Q..HORAAMY O WE HWE
QORWHT ALWLKN
E RI>>N ATHATOE EU TEY YOWRAIOTO
LSHAMECTALAD,  I RUSSHTH KUE
ATREHEW TITHS.L BUS G USTINS
TTE SA, >>GE
IT T OD T
OFPE
ONERN R LEOFOFTOSIE S  T  SIO
BENOW HEAUNIRU R AITINGEAT TTUGN
IOOFFI NF 'S
S T  TIFHIRE
ISIN
OTYE G C OOF'RINAZ YSH EL
TES ITS.T E RESH
Y
BUOR